lo que tenemos aquí es una pregunta de
respuesta libre que podrías encontrar en
un examen tipo app de microeconomía que
tratan de la teoría de juegos y nos
dicen panza llena y bocadillos soleados
son los únicos dos restaurantes de
emparedados que operan en un pequeño
pueblo ok
estamos en una situación de oligopolio
solo tenemos pocas empresas y nos dicen
cada restaurante puede optar por fijar
un precio alto o uno bajo par a sus
emparedados la siguiente matriz de pagos
muestra la ganancia diaria para cada
combinación de precios que los dos
restaurantes pueden elegir la primera
entrada muestra la ganancia de pan se
llena y la segunda entrada muestra la
ganancia de bocadillos soleados si
suponemos que ambos restaurantes conocen
la información que se muestra en la
matriz contesta lo siguiente ok
solo para estar seguros que estamos
entendiendo este problema pensemos un
poco en esta matriz esta matriz nos dice
por ejemplo que pan se llena puede
elegir cobrar precios altos o precios
bajos mientras que bocadillos soleados
también puede elegir comprar precios
altos o precios bajos si panza llena
elige cobrar precios altos y bocadillos
soleados elige cobrar precios altos
entonces lo que nos dice esta matriz es
que la ganancia por día de panza llena
será de 105 pesos mientras que la
ganancia por día de bocadillo soleado
será de 110 pesos
después tenemos la situación donde panza
llena elige cobrar precios bajos y
bocadillos soleados elige cobrar precios
altos en cuyo caso panza llena hace 120
pesos y bocadillos soleados hace 80
pesos también podemos ver las ganancias
cuando en bocadillos soleados elige
comprar precios bajos y ya que panza
llena elige a cobrar precios altos o
cuando ambos eligen cobrar precios bajos
bueno con esto en mente intentemos
responder las preguntas
el inciso a nos dice cada restaurante
tiene una estrategia dominante para
establecer un precio alto o una
estrategia dominante para establecer un
precio bajo o no tiene estrategia
dominante bien pausa el vídeo e intenta
encontrar la respuesta y sólo como una
pequeña pista o un recordatorio una
estrategia dominante es una estrategia
de independencia es decir que sin
importar lo que hagan los otros
jugadores esa será tu mejor decisión una
estrategia dominante para establecer un
precio alto sería que sin importar lo
que decidan elegir los otros jugadores
ya sean precios altos o bajos tu mejor
elección será elegir precios altos pausa
el vídeo e intenta ver si puedes
encontrar la respuesta
bien veamos cuál es la mejor situación
para panza llena bueno sabemos que puede
elegir precios altos o bajos ahora sí
bocadillos soleados elige precios altos
que debería elegir panza llena bueno
estamos en la columna de aquí y estos
son los dos valores que puede obtener
panza llena si bocadillos soleados elige
precios altos
entonces panza llena puede elegir
precios altos y obtener 105 pesos o
elegir precios bajos y obtener 120 pesos
sin bocadillos soleados elige precios
altos panza llena debería elegir precios
bajos entonces déjame notarlo si
bocadillos soleados
elige precios altos entonces panza llena
debería elegir precios bajos ahora qué
pasa si bocadillos soleados elige
precios bajos bueno si bocadillos
soleados elige precios bajos entonces
tenemos de nuevo dos opciones para panza
llena ya sea obtener una ganancia por
día de 40 pesos al elegir cobrar precios
altos porque muchos de sus clientes se
irán a bocadillos soleados en esta
situación o elegir una ganancia por día
de 75 pesos al cobrar precios bajos
incluso si bocadillos soleados elige
comprar precios bajos la mejor elección
para panza llena sigue siendo comprar
precios bajos y lo escribiremos
panza llena debe elegir precios bajos
por lo tanto puedes ver que para panza
llena sin importar que elija bocadillos
soleados su mejor elección es cobrar
precios bajos por lo tanto panza llena
tiene como estrategia dominante elegir
cobrar precios bajos
ahora necesitamos hacer un análisis
similar para ver cuál sería la mejor
estrategia para bocadillos soleados
veamos si panza llena elige precios
altos que debería elegir bocadillos
soleados bueno veamos panza llena elige
el precio alto entonces bocadillos
soleados debe elegir precios altos o
bajos bueno tenemos una opción de 110
pesos y otras de 130 pesos si pan se
llena elige comprar precios altos
bocadillos soleados debería elegir
cobrar precios bajos
ok y si pan se llena elige precios bajos
que debería elegir bocadillos soleados
bueno si panza llena elige precios bajos
bocadillos o el día 2 debe elegir entre
obtener 80 pesos si cobra precios altos
y 70 pesos si cobra precios bajos así
que en este caso si pan se llena elige
cobrar precios bajos bocadillos soleados
debería elegir comprar precios altos y
obtener 80 pesos bueno vamos a
escribirlo si panza llena elige cobrar
precios bajos bocadillos o helados
debería elegir cobrar precios altos por
lo tanto bocadillos soleados no tiene
una estrategia dominante no tiene
sentido para ellos cobrar precios altos
o siempre cobrar precios bajos en este
caso si importa lo que haga panza llena
dependiendo de lo que haga pan se llena
su mejor estrategia será comprar precios
bajos si panza llena cobra
precios altos y cobrar precios altos si
panza llena cobra precios bajos lo
escribiré no tiene una estrategia
dominante
inciso b si los dos restaurantes no
cooperan para fijar precios cuál sería
la ganancia para cada restaurante bien
pausa el vídeo e intenta encontrar la
respuesta antes de que lo trabajemos
juntos
bueno ya sabemos que pan se llena tiene
como estrategia dominante elegir precios
bajos por lo que si panza llena eligiera
como estrategia los precios bajos sin
importar lo que elija bocadillos
soleados entonces terminaríamos en esta
fila de aquí por otra parte si estamos
la situación donde panza llena elige
precios bajos sin importar nada entonces
sabemos que tiene sentido para
bocadillos o aliados elegir cobrar
precios altos porque entra a 0 80 pesos
o 70 pesos ellos elegirán 80 pesos y por
lo tanto terminamos en esta columna de
aquí entonces si los dos restaurantes no
cooperan para fijar precios cuál sería
la ganancia para cada restaurante bueno
panza llena tendrá una ganancia de 120
pesos por día
invocando soleados tendrá una ganancia
de 80 pesos por día
y este de aquí es un equilibrio de nash
ya que por sí mismos ninguna empresa
querrá cambiar de estrategia para
optimizar más los precios porque si
estamos en esta celda de aquí y como
bocadillos o aliados no puede cambiar la
decisión de panza llena entonces
bocadillos o helados o si cambia de
estrategia pasará de tener 80 pesos a
tener 70 pesos por lo tanto no tiene
sentido que cambie su estrategia por
otra parte panza llena no puede cambiar
la decisión de bocadillos soleados
entonces si panza llena cambia de
estrategia pasaría de 120 pesos a 105
pesos
por lo tanto elegiría la estrategia que
él es de 120 pesos es decir las empresas
se quedarán en esta celda de aquí o en
el equilibrio de nash
muy bien entonces el siguiente inciso
nos dice el gobierno del pueblo
considera que los precios son muy altos
entonces decide dar un subsidio diario
de 20 pesos a cualquiera de los
restaurantes que elija establecer un
precio bajo para sus alimentos red
dibuja una nueva matriz de pagos bajo el
sistema de subsidio del gobierno como
siempre pausa el vídeo y avanza en el
inciso será interesante
bien vamos a hacerlo juntos vamos a
hacer primero una matriz de pagos con
sus respectivas celdas de 2 x 2 x aquí
tenemos precios altos bajos aquí altos
bajos por acá arriba hablamos de
bocadillos soleados y del lado izquierdo
de panza llena y veamos el gobierno
ofrece un subsidio de 20 pesos eso
quiere decir que vamos a sumar a la
ganancia de la empresa que tenga precios
bajos la cantidad de 20 pesos primero
ambos tienen precios altos entonces no
podrán obtener el subsidio ninguno de
los dos y seguirán en 105 y 110 pesos
diarios respectivamente
ahora sí pan se llena se mantiene con
precios altos en esta celda bueno ellos
seguirán obteniendo 40 pesos pero en
esta situación bocadillos soleados
obtendrá los 20 pesos del subsidio
gubernamental por lo que ellos están
eligiendo tener precios bajos así que
ellos obtendrán 130 más 20 que es 150
pesos y lo pondré en un nuevo color en
rojo ellos obtienen 150 pesos porque
eligen los precios bajos y así obtienen
el subsidio bien en el siguiente caso
panza llena elige los precios bajos por
lo que en esta situación ellos obtendrán
120 pesos más 20 es decir ahora
obtendrán 140 pesos pero esta es la
situación donde bocadillo soleado sigue
comprando los precios altos y por lo
tanto no obtendrá el subsidio seguirá
obteniendo 80 pesos
y por último en esta celda ambos
cobrarán un precio bajo por lo tanto a
ambos les sumaremos 20 pesos de subsidio
panza llena obtendrá 95 pesos y
bocadillos soleados 90 y veamos tenemos
las preguntas por acá abajo nos dicen
usa tu nueva matriz de pagos para
responder lo siguiente desde bocadillos
soleados elegir la estrategia de fijar
un precio alto o un precio bajo explica
usando los valores específicos de tu
nueva matriz bueno pausa el vídeo e
intenta responderla bien vamos a ver a
bocadillos soleados y vamos a hacer el
mismo análisis que hicimos acá arriba
podemos decir si pan se llena elige
cobrar precios altos cuál es la mejor
estrategia para bocadillos soleados
veamos si panza llena tiene precios
altos bocadillos soleados puede ya sea
tener precios altos y obtener 110 pesos
o tener precios bajos y obtener 150
pesos bocadillos soleados elegir a tener
precios bajos en esta situación
y si panza llena tiene precios bajos
bocadillos soleados puede bueno ya sea
tener precios altos y obtener 80 pesos o
tener precios bajos y obtener 90 una vez
más bocadillos soleados elegir a tener
precios bajos en esta situación por lo
tanto podemos escribir qué
ahora bocadillos soleados tiene como
estrategia dominante elegir cobrar
precios bajos
y podemos explicar un poco esto si panza
llena elige precios altos es racional
para bocadillos soleados obtener 150
pesos en lugar de 110 pesos bocadillos
soleados querré obtener 150 pesos contra
110 pesos
eligiendo precios bajos
si panza llena elige precios altos
bocadillos soleados querrá obtener 90
pesos contra 80 eligiendo precios bajos
bien segunda parte las ganancias de
panza llena deberían de aumentar
disminuir o mantenerse igual explica
después de comparar con tus respuestas
de la pregunta b inciso 1 usa los
valores específicos bien pagos el vídeo
y piénsalo un poco
bueno hagámoslo juntos antes del
subsidio panza llena obtenía
ok y lo tenemos acá arriba si los dos
restaurantes no cooperan para fijar
precios cuál sería la ganancia para cada
restaurante bueno dice que panza llena
obtendría una ganancia de 120 pesos
cuando estaba en un estado de equilibrio
de nash
después del subsidio ok
veamos panza llena sigue teniendo como
estrategia dominante elegir precios
bajos ya que si bocadillos soleados
elige precios altos panza llena prefiero
obtener 140 pesos en lugar de 105 y si
bocadillos soleados elige precios bajos
panza llena prefiere obtener 95 pesos en
lugar de 40 de hecho esta vez ambos
tienen como estrategia dominante elegir
los precios bajos por lo tanto
terminaremos en esta celda de abajo
después del subsidio ambos tienen como
estrategia dominante los precios bajos
ambos tienen como estrategia dominante
los precios bajos obteniendo para panza
llena una ganancia de 95 pesos por día
como 95 pesos es menor que 120 pesos
las ganancias de panza llena disminuyen
y eso es todo por este vídeo hemos
acabado